andere ist herzlich willkommen seinem
neuen pokémon befinde mich gerade im
mediapark parkhaus es ist ein park auf
quellen und wir haben gesehen dass da so
ein paar lockt module installiert sind
beiden pokerstop so wollen wir es auf
jeden fall mal hin laufen wir müssen
jeder kiste mit ihr laufen jetzt einfach
mal nach unten zu den modulen und
schauen was da abgeht
wir sehen schon glaube ich darf vorne
soll riesiges loch installiert seine
vorne wo die dixie klos sind traurig da
hinten ist das lockt module wie vorhin
schon gesagt wir schauen uns das ganze
jetzt machen ich habe hier die ganze
zeit komische gps redete wahrscheinlich
eigentlich bin ich schon längst
innerhalb des kreises derzeit bei anime
dass ich außerhalb in das blockmodell
läuft direkt meine damen und herren
haben nämlich direkt neben lockt
natürlich normale leute wären jetzt
sagen nach traumatologie solchen mist
gestalten aber es ist nicht so freunde
denn ich verfolge gerade eine taktik
dass ich ganz viele von format ich fange
jetzt nicht so dass ich irgendwie
traumautos fangen ganz viele tauschen
sie ist astra cc man sich im glück sei
ein dann habe ich 30 minuten lang
doppelte erfahrung kartenformat uhr
gefallen klatsch kameras schon mit den
füßen
also zurück zur taktik ich hab grad 50
tomate bonbons und könnte das derzeit
entwickeln verschicke das aber wieder an
den ich kann nicht verschicken was soll
die scheiße hier was ich auf jeden fall
machen wollte war alle schlechten
pokemon dann zu entwickeln wenn ich das
flugzeug aktiviert habe
ich will ja echt bibel gerne aber das
alles folgt auf platz ein paar schicken
den später räume in denen uns an
da sind ganz viele pokémon trainer aber
ich finde einzig wahre sketche auf mein
gott ein pokémon nachricht bekommen
in den orient rallye mit wp 12 das das
schlechteste pokémon was ich
wahrscheinlich gefangen werden
klasse drauf drückt die daumen drücken
es halt den scheiß kein häuser klappt
wenn erstens die teenie silke 12
glücklich wir haben jetzt wie schon
wahrscheinlich gewerbe taktik realisiert
bekommen wie das bild quasi hier
eingeblendet wird
genau hier ich habe eine partie nie das
heißt er wird drei die bonbons ich
brauch 25 dann kriege ich einen strahl
voran sondern zu akkumulieren
abonieren nicht doch mal
wenn der draconiden nebag mit wps
gestaltet nebula gp 250 ist relativ gut
ich will ja die ganzen niveau lag
irgendwann zugängen hey was fällt dir
eine zu laufen ist nicht normal ist
ausgeschöpft advents ein ei wer
ausgeraubt sie fangen es los muss ein
pokal vergessen was
müssen wir die tradition stehen jetzt
einfach super bälle und versuche das
läge das niveau lag wehrt sich immer was
ist das denn für eine miss gestalt
kommen klasse wurf nebula bitte sei drin
bitte sei drin
alle gucken mich an als würde ich raten
lu gagfah com in jedem video kommen
welche leute
es ging aber ich nehme mir was auf die
schule jetzt erstmal diesem punkt ist ob
hier um so ein bisschen wieder punkte
beendet sagte wann bekommt man die
tabelle bei zuletzt hatte das spiel mit
kann das spiel übrigens nicht spielen
weil ein zu schlechtes handy erkaufen
ich fange einfach während dem laufen
jetzt informa group nach vorn wenn wir
davor stehen das spiel einfach 60
jährige gerade pokémon wenn wir da vorne
stehen befinden wir uns direkt zwischen
zwei pro kopf die gerade mittwoch module
von wert sind verzerrt versehen
versichert den rundtour wie schön fast
so groß wie man ein trauma torwart
gefangenen ja schön
ich versuche schon wieder eine kapsel zu
fangen weil quasi ohne spaß ich habe
letztens ein video bei snap chat gesehen
in der story dritten quartal angezeigt
und kapsel ist richtig schlecht aber
wenn man entwickelt so kaputt
ich treffe die ganze zeit nicht wenn man
das dann super partie entwickelt sollte
echt gute wettkampf punkte haben wir
richtig stark attacken können ich hab's
gefahren
ich stehe übrigens ganz mit einer bank
am start gefahren
das klappt schon noch mal danke
er ist lecker luca ich noch essen 136 in
den nächsten video ich zeige dir dabei
sehr viele nachfragen ich habe als
bestes copen halte diesen alle tot sich
gerade
ich muss gucken was nur darauf wartet
schon hier links gerade meine pokémons
eingeblendet das hat mich ja sehr viele
gefragt so hey mach mal nicht hier so
die als schwachsinn sondern als ernster
das ist ein team eines pokémon ist ein
hypno ich habe allgemein irgendwie 5
6000 hypno
die krassesten pokemons nicht bisher
gefangenes martini in ihrer doktor und
aqaba was ich mir geholt habe aber ein
team ist nicht gut ich bin level 14 so
das ist nicht krass aber ich spiele halt
auch nicht so unfassbar häufig ist sie
eigentlich wollten heute in video
darüber machen wie wir uns zu hause hin
hatten und mit poker vision gucken wo
legendäre pokémon sind und damit dem
auto hinfahren und die versuchen zu
erwischen allerdings hat genau heute
nintendo gesagt wir probieren darf immer
funktionieren darf nicht mehr
funktionieren nichts funktioniert mehr
und heute ist auch ein neues update
rausbekommen das ist jetzt nämlich unter
anderem möglich dass man einfach seinen
charakter wieder individualisieren kann
und es gibt nicht mehr die drei schritte
sondern es gibt gar nichts mehr und die
teile sind auch einfach in der komplett
unterschiedlichen richtungen jedenfalls
ist die reihenfolge nicht mehr richtig
die haben die drei schritte entfernt und
es ist nur noch 71 meter radius um einen
herum ist bescheuert einfach geworden
nach dem update paar sekunden später
jobs ist geflohen was bin ich denn für
ein behinderter spieler mann
ich werde angeguckt wie ein alien
wie kann das du siehst es zwar nicht
aber es ist echt ab ich treffe die ganze
zeit man ist auch sinn mich ausmachen
endlich junge nach gefühlten 20 jahren
wenn er jetzt aus betreut ich hab ein
langweiliges pokémon video aller zeiten
der loop also musste ich abraten schicke
gefangen willst du vielleicht sagen wir
es entdeckt hat omid s entdeckt b107 es
nicht so ich konnte mein china schon
längst in sherlock entwickeln wissen ich
habe 30 schicke bonbons aber ich will
einfach abwarten ob diese glückssache
wir sind jetzt gerade hier im parkhaus
und ich habe ein nebula gedacht eine
volatile damen und herren wir versuchen
jetzt an ebola viren park aufzufangen
der hof war nicht der allerbeste aber da
passierte nichts mehr
was kannst du eigentlich
es geht nicht ich wollte heute
eigentlich halt davon mit dem glück sei
irgendwie probieren und jo alles klar
ich wollte das eigentlich mit dem glück
zu probieren und jetzt einen noch meine
kämpfe wieder nach oben gehen aber da
kommen noch bis heute pokemon wie klappt
das alles nicht gut ich habe ja kann
jetzt heißt sondern spiele luft draußen
alles ist apropos komisch die ganze zeit
mit ein bisschen humor version zu testen
ist ich hab hunger und was essen gehen
ich habe hunger auf kuchen und nie
freunde wenn es euch trotzdem vielleicht
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung von freud im nächsten wochen
wieder wieder den ich mir schon auf
meiner cap dann autos nicht auf